(indistinct chatter)
(soft music)
- [Reporter] These videos show the moment
thousands of rioters charged
through Brazil's Congress,
presidential Palace and Supreme Court.
Supporters of former
President Jair Bolsonaro
smashed windows and ripped up documents.
The scenes reminiscent
of the January 6th ride
on the US Capitol came amid protest
over Brazil's election results
and days after the inauguration
of Luiz Inácio Lula da Silva.
In the lead up to the vote,
Bolsonaro alleged election
fraud without evidence
and he left the country
after the election.
So as tensions rise between supporters
of the two main political
factions in Brazil,
(indistinct chatter)
here are the key moments in
the months leading to the siege
that can help us understand
how and why the chaos unfolded.
First, let's rewind to late October.
That's when leftist, Luiz
Inácio Lula da Silva,
won the presidential election runoff.
The vote was the closest
in the country's history
with Da Silva taking 50.9% the
vote to 49.1% for Bolsonaro.
It was also a highly polarizing campaign.
(speaking foreign language)
With voters on the left and on the right,
divided over issues
including economic insecurity
and Brazil's handling of the pandemic.
(speaking foreign language)
Following the loss, Bolsonaro
supporters show their anger
by camping outside military barracks
calling for the army to
remove the president-elect.
(crowd protesting)
In his first remarks following his defeat,
Bolsonaro thanked his supporters
and said he'd followed the country's rules
but he didn't concede and he
didn't congratulate Da Silva.
(speaking foreign language)
And the same day protests
from his supporters continued,
truck drivers blocked
roads across the country
rejecting Bolsonaro's loss.
The crowds only began to disperse
after Bolsonaro's government
confirmed the transition
toward a new administration
and asked supporters
to stop blocking roads.
(speaking foreign language)
But more unrest followed.
When Da Silva's election
victory was certified
by the federal court,
Bolsonaro supporters held a series
of violent protests in Brasilia.
A bus was set on fire, leading to arrest.
(speaking foreign language)
At the end of December,
Bolsonaro encouraged his supporters
"not to throw in the towel."
(speaking foreign language)
On the same day, the outgoing
president left his country
and photos from ROTA show that
Brazil's equivalent of Air Force one
landed in Orlando, Florida.
That meant he was out of the country
for Da Silva's inauguration
ceremony in Brasilia.
And when protestors targeted
Brazil's most important
government buildings.
(guns firing)
Police in Brazil detained
more than 1500 people
accused of taking part in the unrest.
And the Supreme Court removed
Brazilian's Federal District Governor,
a Bolsonaro ally from his post.
After the siege, Bolsonaro
condemned the acts
saying that any vandalism or
invasion of public buildings
was unacceptable.
A day later, he was briefly hospitalized
after complaining of stomach
pains related to injuries
he suffered years prior
during a near fatal stabbing.
That's according to his wife.
Da Silva visited Brasilia after the riots
and his supporters also
took to the streets.
The current president's
also divisive figure
due to his role in a corruption scandal
as well as for the socialist
policies he put in place
during his first mandate.
He has promised to investigate
how the riots unfolded.
(speaking foreign language)